before
women i was chasing until now i see
women always chasing like that
right a brand of the hermes you know
like beer king or kelly bag you know
like
and then
i have those kind of collection and then
i become like everybody like look at her
i was like
and then i was like when i go to the
beach you know like i just want to show
off like i don't care with this bag i
just put the bag and the understand like
look at me how i just like just to make
a point just make it point you know even
this expensive bag i can do everything
what i want wow
have you ever wondered if you just had a
lot of money would that make you happy
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome back to led live everybody we
have a great show for you today and uh
you know one that i think all of us have
at some point in our lives
dreamt about being wealthy and rich and
chasing after those kind of things in
the world that we all think would make
us happy but at the end of the day we
find that often more often than not it's
a broken road and so i'm very excited to
introduce to you our two guests ramon
and shandy they come all the way from
indonesia
and uh when i heard you guys's testimony
i was absolutely blessed by it and i
think it's something that um a lot of us
need to um you know kind of
take a step back and and listen to the
stories of somebody that's chased after
these things made it successfully and
then realized that you know what this
isn't all cracked up to be what it is so
i'm excited to hear you guys story
before we get into that we have a new
face on our show britney is one of our
newest recruits to our ministry so if
you haven't recognized her before it's
because she's busy in the back hammering
away on our graphics she's our new
graphic designer so welcome to the show
brittany thank excited to have you on
so you guys uh uh
tell us a little bit about um you know
let's start back from the very beginning
um you know did you grow up in
christianity did you have any sort of
faith roots growing up
well i
i grew up in a christian culture in a
religious
culture
where parents
would have us go to the church
do the church thing
and
i went to christian school i grew up
playing music
you know doing the choir we had this um
what do you call it like a boy scout
christian camps and um i went to i
graduated from christian high school
didn't go to christian college but um i
did all the you know what what you would
expect
yeah a christian boy growing up
i even did
in the church i became the the
youth leader and then the deacon and
then the head of the deacon and became
the elder in the church wow at some
point wow
but i had no idea what it really meant
right you know
church is just a church you know i was
always wondering is there anything
behind this a religious thing spiritual
i kind of left the church though you
know even though my my body was in the
church
but just because you know i had i feel
like i felt like i had to go to the
church but you know it's just yeah
yeah both grew up in indonesia yeah yes
i yeah yeah yeah okay so what percentage
of indonesia is christian
well not that much not that big we're
about um
10 to twelve percent i think yeah okay
yeah the rest of it is what muslim
muslim okay
so it's the largest muslim country in
the world wow wow so yeah it's um it's
85 to 90 muslim
muslims are usually known to be very
devout yes very structured yeah very
structured very at least outwardly
religious
so would you say it's that way in
indonesia or is it more lacks or
different
world
middle eastern countries
well indonesia
despite the fact that it's a muslim
populated it's not a muslim government
so in their view the politics is less
what they call it less uh strict or more
relaxed it's a they refuse
to to have like sharia law
but then day to day we we kind of
feel like you know we are being
discriminated against you know
so you know i'm really familiar with
this kind of muslim uh things because my
my dad's side as a muslim so you know i
can't see how they do
until now
and you know in muslim indonesia is
different with muslim other muslim
indonesia is easy
you know but
they really gonna say to us as a
christian that your blood is ticket for
for them to go to heaven it means
you guys need to respect our our
religion you guys not here to teach us
to be to christian don't convert don't
comfort us so you know
your blood like like like if i kill you
oh wow that's that's my dad say to us to
me specific like you know i respect your
choices but please
your blood is ticket for me to go to
heaven it means that
you can make it easier for me to go to i
was like yeah of course but
but you know it's good because
it's just kind make us to be a books you
know for them right yeah so you know
yeah i was like
i tell my dad i'm not gonna teach you
but you know inside my heart you know i
make sure you know you're going to see a
different hope that's it so so i know
we're going to get into this but is do
you see a lot of like transition between
people of the muslim faith going into
christianity i mean is that just like a
big no-no well it's it's not encouraged
you know
they'll give you but it happens it
happens i even heard i've been hearing
that it's happening at the greater rate
that what we hear in the news of course
like this little
but uh yeah we we have a television
ministry in indonesia and now we get
responses from people from different
faiths and including
you know muslims asking for books asking
for bibles and uh you know you know like
deeply asking for practical gospel
depends you see how the success of the
ministry is right
you know we if you common with christian
you know it's easy to see baptism but in
muslim things it's not but our aim is
the second coming i believe that right
now
you know our aim is like
the the challenge is not how them to get
baptist baptized but the challenge is us
how god how us is remain with this kind
of choices how they are they able to see
christ in you that is good that is the
success
that's right yeah and then
that that's a challenge you know like
like we now we stand in the village that
our village is just only us as a
christian family over there
and then
with muslim things you need to
give them like a long-term time
you know long-term investment yeah
long-term investment like us we already
stay 11 years over there now they're
starting to see now they're starting to
believe us
like the muslim people over there if
they have a problem they come to our
our house they tell the story and they
even tell can you pray for us
for muslim things that is really really
like wow big no
wow like so so you guys are you know
both growing up in in wildly kind of
different sounds here um and you had a
departure i mean you were involved in in
church but then you kind of like left
yeah kind of
yeah i left uh
well at about 23 you know
it's it's a common age when when you
start to graduate you you start your own
career you graduate school you leave
home
and then you have your independence then
you start to
lose your
you know whatever your your parents
installed upon you you know especially
this religious you know
traditions i i did just that
and um
i went to
uh chase
whatever everybody else is chasing
which is uh money and uh
fame and uh and all this fun stuff
and did you find uh did you find a
little bit of it get a taste of it well
i think i was 23 when um
i i finished college i i went to school
to become engineer
and then i remember
one time um
a classmate that i didn't really like he
he sort of challenged me
you know what now that we'll finish
school
let's let's let's race to
to the first million dollar in the back
oh that's interesting challenge i think
that's that's that's a good challenge
i don't know if i want to win but you
know yeah let's do it anyway yeah yeah
we were drunk you know we went to a bar
it was just like uh you know that bar
dog shook hands and then okay let's
let's do it so was there a prize between
the two of you
hey no
that kind of stayed in my in my my mind
i just gotta win no there's no time set
or anything you know it's just yeah and
then we we didn't see each other for a
few years after that but i i i went to
indonesia i
i started having my
work my career my business i had a good
business there i had a concession from
the government to
establish this seaport
it was nothing that i invited investors
to start developing and then we made
traffic
and we were moving goods
and then it was growing and i i sold it
to somebody else
and then banked a lot of money you know
wow and then i
bought cars we bought houses and then i
and then i looked at my bank account i
was i was only 29 i think 28 29
and then with all these things i'm i'm
sitting upon
i i look at my bank i had cash i think
it was like six seven million dollars or
something you know oh man and then i
called up that guy hey you know what
yeah hey i beat you
come on now
come on down
i think i i've won the race you know by
far by by good distance from
i i i heard from from friends that you
know he's still uh
trying to make it and everything i just
i just wanted to show it to him you know
just come come see me yeah i live in
indonesia why don't you just come see me
now yeah so i picked up picked him up
with a nice car you know
it consciously um became
um
a drive in my life you know this is this
is good you know
winning
over somebody that you don't like mm-hmm
and then we
i kept going the guy was like
he came to uh visit me and
i'm like did you get that money
no yeah you know no and then
you know it became that that kind of guy
that
that um
it's not nice yeah
yeah so i
and then after
one year two years after that we we sort
of got married
we got married yeah we sort of developed
a relationship and then we finally got
married there you go
and um
yeah i i thought i was going to fix
myself you know i
i was praying
i i was uh asking
god if you're actually there just send
me somebody yeah
send me somebody i think my life is uh
my life is good but there's this
there's gonna be something else in this
life yeah it's it's as much as you get
those things that you're aiming at and
all of a sudden you realize when you get
those things
there's got to be more this this is not
fulfilling
you know i mean so often we hear this in
so many different respects not even just
business or money but you know in fame i
mean we hear this with celebrities all
the time
the celebrity achieves a certain level
of fame and then it's like they're just
as empty if not more so
so you're starting to feel the pull
mm-hmm and you're still really actually
having little conversations with god
yeah yeah i i was uh
um
i was living a life that i i thought oh
this this is it a lot of people a lot of
my friends are are engaging me as a
success
story
that they all want to be
but um you know having
just i i was able to just buy things i
wanted within my own capacity i i think
i i had a lot more than i i needed
i was buying this and that i had cars
and we have
my motorcycle i had my boat i had
everything just properties
cash paid
you know and then just like which girl
that you want to do
he obviously picked the best one
[Laughter]
so how did you two meet then
uh
me and him is very opposite you know
yeah
you know christian funny how god puts
you together right you know and then but
me i was raised like with un you know a
godly family she was raised in a messed
up family i'm really raised with the
messed up family and then you know my
parents always teach me you know you
need to be beautiful you need to be
smart because you know you need to chase
money because you know you cannot be a
rich guy yeah exactly not just only that
my dad like he just very careful with my
skin
for him be careful you know you need to
have like very
nice skin because someday if you get
married with the
rich people they love like very
i was like
okay it's just like always
on my mind and then
i just dating of course yeah she became
materialistic
[Laughter]
no money no honey for me
even even you love me but you don't have
money i'm sorry i'm busy
you begin to see people only in their
value and what they have i mean that
value can change yeah i mean like like
that's such a false view of who somebody
is actually but this is what you were
chasing yeah yeah because my parents
told me like that like you know change
money uh chasing money and then without
money you cannot be happy
so you know i believe that i raised with
with grown up like that so that's why
you know big you know on my mind just
money money money
and then
but
i don't know
i kind of i can't feel something empty
but i'm curious because
my age at the moment like 21 and then i
have the accessibility accessibility to
have
private uh airplane mm-hmm and then i
can't choose what it wasn't for me
i was dating
a very rich person she was dating a
millionaire she was dating a billionaire
seriously
so within within wealth there's these
different levels where it's like oh yeah
yeah yeah even when you're in the
millionaire range right that's a lot of
money to a lot of people i i i don't
know what that world's like right yeah
but then the billionaires it's like oh
these people are just you know right
yeah wow so
uh but i don't know why when i almost we
met but
but when when i almost want to reach
that level
i kind of so scared i was like wow and
then you know inside my heart i just
thinking like
no no i'm not i'm not look for this kind
of
happiness you know money i don't know
who teach me because my parents never
teach me but you know the holy spirit i
believe that is holy spirit i believe
because you know when i become a
missionary
i get to that some first that you know
from the day that you were in the
mother's womb you know god knows you i
was like wow he knows me even you know
even everything you know my environment
my family always pushed me to that level
but there's something to obviously you
know stop me that no
no and then i almost want to get
everything you become
you become a millionaire when you are
when you when i was 21
but
i'm praying and i'm fasting because my
dad is a muslim
and then he always teach me that if
you're confused in life if you have a
problem start fasting and then stop
praying
and then i start praying i was and then
i felt like i don't know who are you but
i know that people always call you god
i just need some help i tell like this
is not something that i want actually
but i don't know i don't know the way
but i don't know like because nobody
always come to me and then give me
explanation
i was really lost but i just need some
help from you
please send me a husband
that can get closer you know that person
can get closer to me and you i was like
i just want that and i'm so ready
married with the servant of the lord it
says and i'm already married with the
pastor
and then i teach myself that i don't
want to depend with this kind of
materialistics
and then
god sent him oh suddenly shining armor
walks in
i'm not a billionaire but
yeah i was like confused like lord not
him yeah you know these guys still have
a lot of money and then this guy is you
know party goers like me i'm sorry yeah
and this guy always we you know
we have something coming like if we drop
yeah we look at the body yeah right
right lord how this man can bring me
closer to you it's impossible just send
me pastor or send me anything like
servant of the lord not him
i was like oh
and then you know i always ask you know
the sign i don't know because i don't
know nothing about bible and then sign
is really good you know like god really
works on me with science good
confirmation and then you know i asked
like three sign and it's always him
and then
i tell with my boyfriend i was like i'm
sorry
i hope the answer is your name but the
answer is him and he's just totally
confused you're you you're praying like
how
and then which god that wants to hear
your prayer i was like i don't know but
the answer is him and i start to open my
my heart for him
and
then
when we're getting married
he he spoiled me he gave me everything
because he thought like yeah that's that
i thought that was the only way i was
gonna satisfy satisfy somebody like her
in the beginning i was like oh i'm not
going to marry someone like this you
know coming from that guy yeah to me i
had my money but not like him yeah yeah
but so after we got married we we we
were just i i was just um
sort of uh
spoiling her thinking that it was like
something that she wanted
but she's like nah this is not what i
wanted if i wanted money i would have
just married that guy you know i got
more than you yeah
i'm enjoying too yeah uh scott was
asking how we met you know we met four
years before we got married
how do we meet we met in the church wow
we didn't mean in the bar or whatever
but even though
we were jewish people i did my church
thing
just so happened that i went to to the
church you know that one one church
service
i met her she she had friends because
she went to the christian school
even though she wasn't a christian she
wasn't um
she was whatever you were right
and then she she had friends that
brought her to church sometimes hey come
to church sometime so she came and then
that day we met in the church
but when we were in dating we just kind
of knew each other we had like a common
social friends you know and then we
and then we met outside the church of
course we would hang out with um not
church people um
she was asking for for signs from
god
i was actually i had more structure
requests you know i had more structure
system i belief you know
i thought
and um
i it was a new year's
eve i was i was out partying with
friends you know we went down to europe
just when the run of the car drove to
spain and then to
morocco and then we had fun there and
then
i i was
new year's eve i was praying you know
lord my my my life is empty
it's fun i could do but there's no chat
no more challenges like you know what do
i do now
and uh when when your heart's not with
the lord your money becomes dangerous
you know i i've been through just you
know drugs and fun partying buying
things that i don't even need
right um
i was a social drug user i was in she
was suicidal with drugs
suicidal because she had like
she she had family that gave her reasons
to and then that that that that um
no no friday night uh new year's eve i
was praying specifically lord sent me
somebody
apparently she was praying for the same
same body
wow and then i said god send me somebody
i think my life is a mess
i thought a wife would be able to fix me
that's a wife's job right yeah right
right
and then i was praying specifically lord
send me somebody and then i was holding
up this uh this quarterly right we get
from church i i i bring it
everywhere i go i never read it but i
just have it you know like bye but i put
bible in the pillow just that kind of
christian thing that's what i thought
would do magic
i held up this quarterly i said lord
i know you're almighty i know you hear
my prayer i i know you love me right
even though i'm messed up like this but
send me somebody i need i need somebody
i think it's time for me to
i'm done with all this uh party you know
whatever
i know how to look for girls but i don't
know how to look for wife
so just show me somebody i want that
person to get
asked to get baptized before this book
ends i looked at the end of the book it
was going to end the 26 march
like okay i i want to make a serious
deal here with you
bring me somebody before this book and
okay i dropped it and then in january
february march
i i i started to remember my my prayer
oh yeah i was asking for something from
the lord three months ago but nothing's
happening here
well he's probably not serious
and then that
that
week before the book
ended right
we were supposed to go out
you know she was with somebody i had my
you know my somebody too and then
hey you know what they'll tell those
guys you know we're not able to meet up
because that weekend before that book
ended uh we had a church retreat
she's like church retreat
if you were that involved you know
and then i said yeah yeah yeah what is
that church between you know we go to uh
you know get a chalet up in the mountain
or on the beach sometimes or you know
this this time we're
booking a little villa in the in the
mountain with the whole church
can i come
like you want to come
i'm like i was a little bit embarrassed
you know
i didn't want to tell her that i was at
least
she knows what
during the the church retreat you know
friday saturday saturday night we were
talking she was just being attentive and
then saturday night after sundown she
goes to the pastor and say pastor you
know what i want to talk to you
pastor says okay let's go to that corner
we talk and then they talk for a few
minutes i don't know what they talked
about but
after a few minutes the
pastor calls me hey come here
your friend here
wants to get baptized
she wants to join our church
and then you know what
she was so persistent with the pastor
she she said look i
i felt like a strong desire i i want to
make up my mind wow um her mother was
christian but not not the kind of
christian that went to church ever and
never had the bible never
but she was like leaning towards what
she was being taught by mom rather than
muslim dad
and then anyway that
saturday night she said pastor i want to
get baptized okay we'll put you on a
bible study and everything no no no no
no no no no
cut that i want to get baptized now yeah
this week
awesome
and then pastor was like wow this woman
is serious okay let's meet up in my
office yeah we met up following monday
and then
we sat down and i'm like oh lord this is
not happening
i wanted somebody but not her i like her
no there's something in my mind in my
heart that
this is this could be marriage quality
but you know she's
dating this how am i going to feed
somebody like this is like a spending
monster
[Laughter]
but i i i
and then monday and then i said lord if
this is your will
open up my heart yeah you know to accept
the possibilities you know this is
probably really not yeah she was really
she's his wife quality maybe but more
like not you know
and then
that wednesday the church decided okay
let's bring sandy to the ocean on the
north coast of jakarta
and then we baptized her on wednesday
wow two days before that book ended
wow
i'm like and after she got baptized she
comes out of the water changed and
everything
i told her you know what cindy
you did
my god tells me you're my wife
and she said you know what
i've been praying also
you know the sign is always leading to
towards you as my husband wow
like how do you feel about that she said
i'm not happy about that
my feelings mutual you know
but we're gonna make it work i love it
though you guys both responded in the
same way though you know what i mean
that's that really speaks to you guys
listening to the holy spirit and how
much we fight against it sometimes it's
like the holy spirit's like like i don't
know how much more plain i can make this
for you but uh that's the person you're
supposed to be with you know we got
married two months after that wow praise
god it was not smooth marriage um
um
because you were still holding on to
some of these old you know ways and
trying to incorporate that in yes
interesting yeah it's a it's a process
you know you expect things to be rainbow
and butterfly yeah
no god gives you something you take it
you you think oh it's going to be all
beautiful no it's not like that at all
yeah the process of
coming
uh living the life of flesh into the
life of spirit yeah there's a journey so
you know there's some first right first
set if you believe you will see the
glory of god
but the kiss
are you believe that you believe like
every time i saw my husband i was like
oh why him yeah like lord i'm so
confused
you know the glory has left views
are you really send him to me and he's
also like that you know because why
every day i never i never sober like
every day i always like take my you know
alcohol like my uh drugs like every
single day i cannot i cannot normal like
this you know
normal it's me like
i never of course you know there's no
drugs anymore right in our life i hope
so
i cannot i just need to you know to do
to take drugs and alcohol then i can
talk
yeah you know and we always like even
even we have kids you know my boys
always see me like
you know bust out mess out and then all
of uh and all of my assistant gonna
explain to them like you know it's okay
your mommy is just a little bit tired
but no i'm not tired i was like
yeah and then i every time he saw me too
like lord look at this women look at my
life
this is the woman you sent me i'm really
dysfunction you know and then um and
then he's he's always give me like i
don't know you know
and then i become like the icon of with
my family and my society like if you
want to be success you need to be like
shandy and ramon look at her they're
still young but you know they have
everything even even in the church
you know uh
function they're gonna tell like you
know you need to be success like them
but no
i was i'm really feel
empty
so that's what my husband said like you
know she's very suicidal you know if i
take drugs and i take pills and i take
alcohol i just want to end up myself
every day like i just want to suicide
because i don't have
something that i feel that
you know life is
life is life is boring like i just want
to
lord you know i just want to end it i
just want to end it so every time
even we go to party like everybody like
hi shandy you become a queen
but when you go home
i'm crying my assistant no i just like
crying i was like you don't know and
then my assistant said like cheney you
are so happy did you understand that and
i tell them i tell them i checked them
like
you don't know me you don't know what
i'm feeling
you just you away like i just scream i
just like crying i was like
i just i just lost like much of it has
to do with our brokenness
and uh you know she was abused you know
in many different ways
by parents you know i i was
and um
um she ran away to whatever drugs and
then
you know the money
um i was actually running away also you
know trying to find the answers and then
all this uh money and access to wealth
we think is a solution to keep us
distracted from all this thing you know
but it's really not it's really nice
it's really nice so
in your previous relationship with the
gentleman who was wealthier same thing
drugs alcohol just never sober never
well the thing is he was never really
there that much he lives yeah he lived
in two different places so he's always
traveling yeah
oh yeah but the way our function is like
that
yeah i'm really curious to know um since
like back to your prayer like when
you're praying for your future husband
um and like knowing that you grew up
with like kind of like two different
faiths in your house how did like what
was your view of god and how did you
feel like you could come to him like it
seems like
you thought he was someone who actually
did care to listen to what you had to
say so i guess what was your view of god
since you weren't i guess like fully
christian if i'm
i don't know i just i don't know i just
i just believe that you know for him for
me
if he which is god tell me that i need
to get married with him that's that's
the one that i i think how did you
believe that
what induced the prayer what drove you
to pray
ah so that's why i asked for three signs
right and the sign is always him and i
know that that is not coincidence and i
know that you know it's him
because i think um
i i i could probably
answer that
that's the work of the holy spirit that
we don't realize we have it
no matter what religion or even your
don't believe in anything
you you have the holy spirit
telling you
that
that's the work of the holy spirit to to
to guide you to to counsel you to to
right and put you back in the righteous
path you know and to tell you if
something is wrong i think that's what
um got her to to start praying and
asking and yearning for
so i'm curious
because you you're both coming from
kind of
different yet similar worlds
you see these signs that happen in your
life after you pray to god
and then when god brings you each the
person you're like oh no no no no not
then like not you know but you go
through with it anyway yeah
and then after you get married
now you're experiencing maybe the like
see god i told you this was a bad idea
yeah yeah
what
kept you
together
because
you know it's like yeah you have these
signs and you get you get married and
then you start going about life but the
whole time it sounds like you're
questioning god like
what are you doing like this is terrible
like what were you thinking
i think again that that that is the work
of the spirit that god places upon our
heart you know
you try to do it your own way you know
okay you think god we
treat god like a slave hey i want this i
want that but you know it's um
he doesn't work that way he wants you to
actually enjoy the full life
but not
if you do it the way you've been doing
it
what i mean is like okay now you give me
a wife right right lord okay now she can
satisfy what i need
it's not like that
everything works together to bring good
for those who love him those who are
called according to his plan you know
romans 8 28.
so god gives me this woman in my life
so what
the next verse is it says so the the
image of christ can be restored
right
so the image of christ can be restored
in me
god has to give her
god has to give me her
what is image of christ like all
patience right
how is he going to accomplish that in me
because i mean i was a very impatient
person he gives me the perfect tool
for me to practice patient
so she will be the one to test my
patients every day
so if you look at that right is that
what you were thinking at the time i was
really thinking that way you're
i'm listening to you now and you're like
you're coming at it from
10 plus years of experience saying this
is how it works but in the moment yeah
what was it that what was prompting you
to stay together i mean you said the
holy spirit but like were there
questions in your mind like okay god
like you brought this woman to me what
are you doing like what keeps you
together day by day is it just those
little voices of the spirit prompting
you
at what point did you start to awaken
and realize
i need to think differently yeah
i think um i
she was a hard woman to deal with
i was a hard man to deal with for her
you know it's the same he's being fair
you know god gave me god gave her me to
her is also for the character of christ
although she didn't know it you know
loving unconditionally he wants her to
have the love and condition that's why
she was given a man who never meets the
condition yeah yeah yeah you practice
right
but we didn't see that before i kind of
saw that first because you know i have
my christian background you know that's
what the bible is telling us you know
but
i i pushed it lord in it this is this is
not the way
you know i gotta push my my way not your
way
and then if we're both like doing this
we're just going to clash it actually
did
well clashed at some point you know i
i just couldn't handle it anymore i said
let sandy you you know i got a gun there
you just take out the gun just shoot me
in the head man just end this crazy life
you know this is crazy marriage i can't
handle it you know
wow
she she's a
when she's
mad she could just flip the heavy stable
beds all the furniture
super strong right she had this
supernatural power
suddenly from somewhere she could know
why you try flipping the car next time
you know
my wife is the same
but i
i said look okay i can't take this
anymore lord i know you're making a
mistake man you're not making a mistake
maybe i don't know how to approach this
properly you know
to um um
to live up according to what you have
given me
and then i said shoot me here in the
head tell me shoot me in the head
and she said no
no okay you know i was i was scared to
kill myself you know i want to die but
in the schedule
so i took other she said she had this
stiletto the high heel start puncturing
myself with it you know wow
okay let's let's make this suffer let's
end this really really this is the way
you really want me to suffer okay let's
and then
blood which is crushing just all over
the the room
i saw my uh i felt my
my my the skin just sort of drooped
because there's a big gush here on on my
head
and then i thought i was gonna die you
know i started lose so much blood and
then
the house staff the the security of the
driver
just busted the door open they found me
like it all lay
in bed took me to the hospital
and then in the hospital i'm like i
thought i was gonna die and then i i
slept i don't know what they gave me and
they stitched up my head and i woke up
and then i said wow lord you know what
this is really going to end really bad
i got to really
try a different approach here wow you
know
and then i said you know what i want to
do it differently now wow you know if i
die maybe okay you know if i don't die
and then i become like um
vegetable that's not going to be good
you know
i i got to do it differently so you you
almost got to like rock bottom yes i
think that was my rough bottom line yeah
yeah and then you were like i realize my
way doesn't work that's right i'm ready
to try something different yeah what i
think is really nice though listening to
your story is you guys are having this
crazy tumultuous like you know
like crazy yeah
like literally for lack of a better term
yeah yeah but you're still having these
conversations with god yeah you're still
opening your heart going and this is the
patience of god like he he just allows
us to say you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna let you try it your way and yeah
and i'm right here yeah you know i'm
right here and it's like that constant
opening your heart to him and he goes
i'll show you a better way
let me show you a better way yeah
yeah because we need to focus upon us
because i believe that god need i don't
know god needs to allow the crisis
you know that marriage for us is a
crisis
and then we have we have house
houses we have houses so every time we
we you know we it's so convenient we
always you know
don't bother me
and then
you know i have my own time i always
think like wow you know
he's not going to be wrong which is god
you know and then that's i believe that
that is the holy spirit tried to talk to
me and then i think like you know if i
messed up it means that i'm the one who
see everything's wrong
because you know god sent him
you know he's going to be
right person who's going to bring me
closer to god
i just need
i just need time i just put time you
know for for me to gonna see
if everything is on the right direction
so every time we we fighting we go to
this to the different houses
and then why we we always be together
again because of the prayer because of
the the sign and i i believe that he's
he's not wrong
i always told him like you know ramon if
we messed up with this uh
marriage
you know it's mean that you and me
we messed it up we messed it up and then
god knows like god even give me
a children
god just give me like one month and
after that i'm pregnant i was like that
fast
i was like no
i want to enjoy life you know but
it doesn't happen it doesn't happen
and then i believe that is not
coincidence you know every time i see my
children i was like no i need to do
something
i don't want them to experience what i
experience
you know even i'm pregnant you know i
take my alcohol everything you know i
become a plane base i'm playing base why
i playing bass because i want my
children to be like him
yeah but i mix with my style
you know the one that i know i'm doing
that one so but i'm playing bass because
i want my children like him you know
like very simple with food and
everything you know
so uh that's the one that i i know when
i have i having my boy
when i see
when i see the baby i was like wow
god trusts me with this soul and
i better be responsible yeah i tell
you know we we we better do something
perhaps god gave you that baby quickly
yeah because maybe you know tragic would
have happened
yeah and it's like all of a sudden you
know these these situations that god um
orchestrates for us to be in
um really are there to to shape our
character back into the image of christ
and and you know what is the image of
christ it's it's a
sacrificing of yourself so that someone
else can have a better existence that's
really what what what jesus was was
willing to do right and the joy becomes
yours anyway that's right that's right
and so in a marriage situation um i
think the most amazing
marriage is when you look at it going
how can i bless this other person how
can i make their life a blessing and
vice versa when you have that two mutual
things together that's that's yeah the
other thing i think is is interesting is
you know i think back on my own
experience i don't know that i would
have picked
my wife
you know
and i don't know if you can say the same
or not but i i don't know like of all of
all the people that were around
i don't know that i would have thought
yeah like that's the right one to pick i
don't know that i would have had that
foresight but god had the right
foresight you know and of course i'm
very happy and i think god made the
right choice for me
but i don't know that i would have made
the right choice you know so it's
important to let god make that choice
even
if it winds up being like world war iii
in the beginning yeah
well i think everybody goes through that
experience right i mean i i went through
that certainly a year after my marriage
i was like lord what'd you do to me why
did you give me this person it just took
me two weeks yeah yeah yeah i took two
weeks for a divorce asking for divorce
in the beginning i mean my wife could
have done no wrong but then a year into
it you're just like wow this person is
just so different than me but it was
really through that working through that
that we began to really appreciate each
other and now it's like i can't see
myself ever being with anyone else i
mean i tell my wife all the time you
know there's not going to be marriage in
heaven but sorry babe you're stuck
we're not ending this thing here
i think that's what life is all about
you know many people give up and this is
not only marriage everything you know
because there's a process
you know um
if you want something we want it now we
want it quick you know we're not we're
not willing to deal with the process
uh looking from christian perspective
whatever is borne by the flesh is flesh
whatever is born by the spirit spirit
transitioning from this life to that
life doesn't take you know yeah like
that you have to go
there's a process you're preparing
understanding that you know your own
weaknesses this is the area that you're
going to be so vulnerable you know you
have to acknowledge those steps and it
doesn't happen overnight
many young people are actually just
giving up because of this
in making the career choice making the
marriage choice and then they give up
before they see that it feels cool
and then just because no i i don't think
i want to deal with this i don't know if
this is like a culture here in america
also i'm like oh you don't deserve that
you deserve somebody better right throw
it away
so be done with it
a couple of things
when you got
pregnant
if i understood you right you were doing
drugs yeah and drinking
and your your first child is fine yep
that's fine that's a miracle he's very
functional
and now he's become a missionary too
yeah that's a miracle
now the other thing i i kind of wanted
to to
maybe bring out for our audience is oh
don't do that oh yeah
some of these things we're talking about
are past tense you've had
houses you've had
you know all these things
which the implication is you don't have
them anymore yeah
um
so do you have any regrets
well
not at all not at all i know it's so
don't miss the the money the lifestyle
the anything well it's so many
inconveniences you know well
we've
we've become
we became missionaries you know um
after how many years we are married
about six years uh into the fifth year i
started to realize my own identity you
know after the accident whatever i said
look lord i want to come back to you
show me the way
you know i was the person that my whole
family has been praying was praying a
lot for you know
uh i lived in well when i was younger
you know i come over at four o'clock in
the morning and my whole family would be
up in the at four o'clock in the morning
having their morning worship reading
bible
[Laughter]
and then i i i told him look you know
it's not my time yeah when i when i when
i come i'm gonna come strong you know
but not now now it's time for me to
sleep
but um yeah
my my point is that i when i became uh
when i i was in the intersection what am
i gonna do here you know my my identity
was like a flash before me again and
like you gotta do it god's way not your
way and then i said lord you know if i
want to go i've been telling you i want
to go all the way
i think um
at that time there's so many things
happening and then after we got married
money started to just come in still
uh but problems with marriage is just
like hell you know
and then i said lord i know you can fix
this
i think i'm done with this life i think
i want to come to you straight and i
uh go uh do my life according to your
will what you have set out for me to do
and then i i knew i was going to just
become somebody that's fully for the
lord
you know no no more lukewarm
can't be in both worlds i remember my
prayer in july 2008 i said to the lord
lord if you desire me to live like a
worldly person you know doing all this
worldly thing
you know leave me alone how come i'm not
at peace doing this
how come there's like a voice to to to
remind me this is not where i should be
if this is what you desire me to be then
they leave me alone
you know i'll come give me peace doing
this i see so many worldly people doing
this they're at peace about it no how
come i'm not they look like they're at
peace at it yeah yeah how many times
have we heard this story
it's like you see the people from the
outside you're looking in the window and
you're going well outside they have such
a wonderful life and then this is
happening at home yeah inside what i
meant also is that they have like no
conscious you know wrong conscience
about doing this well i do you know
but if you design me for a completely
different purpose if you designed me
to serve you
all my time is for you all my family is
for you all my money is for you all my
life my future my everything about my
thought my words everything about me is
for you
then take me there wow and teach me how
to hate that because i love this
even though i'm not at least doing this
teach me how to live there because i
don't know it it's it's like almost
how we got married you know lord my
thought my i wanted that but that's not
there you tell me to take this but i
don't know how to do this
it was the same thing it was the same
experience all over again but this time
we were married you know
if you want me to be there take me there
and then he was actually slowing stowing
slowly taking me
restoring my character i guess you know
and then for the first
after that prayer in july 2008
and then
he sort of changed me a little bit to
become more patient and everything and
then i sort of become a different person
in front of her wow that was like
um
uh attracting her wow were you worried
that she was gonna be like uh no that's
not what i signed up for
that's what she said maybe you're not a
billionaire but you know you're at least
that's that's what she said so when i
was like making a return to the lord oh
like sandy you know what our life you
know
you you told me you pray
to god i pray to god this is
don't you think there's a different lie
that he had designed for us
and this is not it
this is really not it
you know you want somebody to bring you
closer to god
i i think i know the way
i think the way is this
everything that belongs to us
doesn't belong to us
it's true our time doesn't belong to us
our money doesn't belong to us our
children don't belong to us our future
doesn't belong to us what does that mean
i don't know how i don't know the
implication of this
but
all these things are going to change it
really puts it into perspective even the
way you look when you're doing drugs and
things like that right because if you
look at it like that like this is not my
money what am i doing with this with
this resource here
that god has allowed me to to manage and
take care of and i'm using it on myself
you know it's really interesting now how
that's changing are you following along
with how he's kind of changing i mean
are you
fighting against this as well i'm really
fighting you know like
i even asked for the divorce you know
when i see him to that go to the
direction
we become like very
you know
different person and i tell him like uh
do you realize that you find me in that
life
and now you want me to go to that life
why because i've been exposed in the
church to see the
the wife of the pastor and the wife of
the servers that i mean surface servant
and then i just like very when i look at
them i was like oh wow
that's how she look they don't they
don't i don't know how they enjoy life
you know i see from the bottom to the
top i was like oh wow i cannot be like
them you know i really very
i love my diamond i love my watch i love
my back i don't know you know women
always i don't know
before
women i was chasing until now i see
women always chasing like the
brand of the hermes you know like beer
king or kelly bag you know like
and then
i have those kind of collection and then
i become like everybody like look at her
i was like
and then i was like when i go to the
beach you know like i just want to show
off like i don't care with this bag i
just put the bag and the understand like
look at me how i just like just to make
a point just make it point you know even
this expensive bag i can do everything
what i want
and then i cannot imagine that
i'm not live like that you know i cannot
imagine you know so that's why when he
go to that direction
i'm the one like oh no no no no no i
cussed them with this kind of things and
then not just only that my environment
tell me like shandy you just divorce
with ramon
you know there's a millionaire and
billionaire just go back in the market
just go back to the market you know and
that's it and then one week you just can
get
you know and i was i don't know i
i see my children again i was like no
it's no no i was and then but every time
i go to the church
i always see a godly woman
and i tell him like ramon
it's good for her it's good for you to
get married with her
and she can she can teach our children
to become a godly children
and then ramon said like are you crazy
come on i tell him
me
become a wife of a missionary
can you see from the bottom to the top
ramon even my nails it's a powerful
i was like come on even my eyes did you
see like
someone even my hair i cannot live with
my because i have my um
hair stylist you know my own hair
stylish my makeup artist i can just sit
do everything i was like come on
you know when you preach about the lord
and then when the people see like look
at you why why don't you pray
to your wife first like come on just
leave me alone i tell everyone and then
you stop praying and ask god to change
me
i know your god is big
but i know
i'm really weak and i can be crazy if i
say yes to change
you know to that kind of direction
and then ramon my husband always like no
i believe that you are the answer
i believe that you're going to be my
partner in the in
the future someday
and i tell him like no and then i
remember one time we have a big party my
my friends come to l.a
and then we
we have a big event
you know i just drinking and everything
they come from
yeah they come from los angeles and then
i come i i come home
and then i see my husband you know
reading a bible and then i just put
every time of reason
every kind of reason for him to divorce
with me
you know my my assistant bring me you
know and then
i just messed up i just you know lying
on my bed and then he always come to me
because he know if he touched me in here
i just get angry so that's why he
touched me in my uh kakidoba
and he stopped praying like lord
you know
sandy is the answer of my prayer
and i don't know when and how you're
gonna i believe that you're gonna change
her you know lord you know just give me
passion to wait for her
i you know in i listening i was like oh
man
this guy is praying for me
and i'll i don't know for me that is
amazing i was like wow he's really have
a passion to wait for me and i was like
lord
you know even even though i'm wrong i
said like lord
just do something
just do something i
anything you know look at me i don't
know how to start and then i remember
when he out from the room i go to my
closet i see my mirror i was like look
at me
look at the way i dress look at my
makeup look at even my nails
how i'm gonna how i'm gonna change i say
like lord
just leave me alone
just send a wife for him and then not
because i tell him not because i don't
love you i love you so much but i know
that
i just want to be
a realistic that
it's impossible for me to go to your
direction
and then i don't know how
you know like one time because i always
see him right you know read the book
and then i see through that book he
changed a lot
and
i cannot sleep i always cannot sleep i
always sleep like seven a.m in the
morning
i cannot sleep and then one time and
then my room is like this like no lights
at all like make sure there's no lights
at all
and then
one time he go out and i go to the to
his desk because i saw through this book
he can change
and then i just grabbed one book
and the book is
stuck to christ
i show yeah i get the book
and i started praying i was like
give me something you know
and then
i read the book
and i'm crying i feel something is
something missing in my life is already
like
been
what is it
being filled and i'm trying crying
crying i was like wow this book is
awesome
what book is this i was like wow and
then
i'm crying i was like lord this is this
is the answer that i've been looking for
the rest of my life and i found from
through that book i'm crying and then
but when i'm crying i get angry because
i don't want to change i just like throw
the book at all through the book i was
like no i don't want to change
but i'm very curious because you know i
feel like when you when you dry when
you're thirsty and you drink water and
you feel fresh right i felt i've
i
fresh i feel something you know like
that and i start
uh reading the book again the book and
then after that
he knocked the door and he said like
sandy you know just open the door and i
just want to make sure he don't
he
don't look at me
you know read the book and i'm crying
because i don't i don't want to it's not
a good sign it's not a good sign
i was like no
and then you know i was like i was like
no no no
and then
he come inside and he said like
you know
what what are you doing and i said like
nothing
and then i tell him like why you go home
so fast
and he said like no
so that's why sandy you don't need to
put the skirt in because you don't know
outside it's already morning or it's
night you know when i open the curtain
it's already night can you imagine i
never read wow i just write i just like
to read like fashion
kind of books you know that is the whole
day yeah i read the whole day
morning till night wow and from that i
was like
wow
you are strong i was like wow
okay i can count on you i tell it so
that's why you know from that start you
know i feel the the his power
i starting like so hungry
i read bible like
wow
and then
one time because i never i never can
sleep right
and then
one time like i i i cannot sleep
and then i go out from the from the room
and i see him always sit in that
chair
every day read his book
and then
i go out
and i thank god because he not put like
how right yeah yeah no
he's just so cool he's just really cool
and then i sit there i'm reading i'm
reading and then
uh like lord start to
pop up
yeah restore restored and then
i start to ask him like ramon what is
this
and then
i start to ask like ramon i need uh i
need a new book
can you tell me which book that i need
to read
and then he give me a
home about
adventist uh
home
and then from that book i start to read
you know
the job as a wife i was like wow
and then i was like wow mind-blowing and
then i started to read how to teach my
children
wow and then i tell him come on give me
the other book and then he gave me
started making conversations yeah i
started making conversation and then
you know it takes like years for us to
to to read the book and then
yeah and then one time i asked him ramon
i already read all of this book
and then i just from this book i learned
that you are the priest in this family
and i want to applicate that to my life
apply that apply that to my life because
for women like me
say him as my leader is no no right i
was like okay
now i need
now i need to ask you something
you know because
you are the you are the priest in the
family
and then i want i i want to have you
know uh the life that
you know the action life you know like
you you need to watch like uh what do i
do about this what do we do what do we
do it's completely different than and
what we're doing yeah yeah and he looked
at me and he said
the way you dress
i don't know when and where but god will
change you
and he said
are you ready to go to that
direction
people like me when you know when the
man said like you need to change
oh wow that is my idol
i need to make sure when i stop you know
i step out the door i need to make sure
that you know i'd be a queen you know
like queen
you know i was like and then he said
like
are you ready and i was like yes i'm
ready what else
and he said you know everything that we
have our money our properties our cars
everything
we we're going to give everything to the
lord and you and me
we're going to learn
to live very simply life and then we're
going to learn with faith live with
faith
are you ready to allow god to take
everything what we have and i said like
yes i'm ready
what else i said with ramon and then
ramon says maybe someday in the future
maybe i even don't have money to provide
for the children's school
are you okay with that
yes i'm okay what else come on and he
said like
maybe someday
god will allow you to have a very deep
uh
disappointment disappointment come from
my church come from my family
even come from me
are you ready
to go to very deep disappointment in
life comes with god i tell him yes
i'm ready and then you know
he hold my hand and he said like wow for
me that is very like wow lord just take
me and then he come he just grabbed my
hand and he said like but you know i
will pray to the lord and i ask lord
lord
if you're willing please bring me and my
hus my wife and my children go to heaven
together
and for me that is a calling and i said
like lord
just take everything i don't need
everything i just need the love come
from him you know the confidence to tell
like i'm your leader i'm your priest you
know that i will i will bring you
to meet
you know my boss which is god i was like
yo just i just ready yeah and here we
are now right
[Laughter]
it took few years yeah
yeah but finally but that's the beauty
of god is is
he doesn't expect
tonight you need to do this and this and
this you know what i mean he works with
us where we're at and even sometimes
it's two steps backwards one step
forward two steps backwards you know and
it's this push pull it's not it's not
just you know
life-changing and everything smooth
sailing from there on out yeah it's it's
it's a rough go i mean you you got to
think the devil has has had his
you know talons in you guys
in many different ways and he's seen
he's losing his grip on you he's not
wanting to let you go he's going to try
his best to to throw confusion to to
divide you to
and the fact that that you know you were
able to just stay the course
and the consistency and and what a model
that is for us parents i mean what a
model that is for for husbands to to
really just say you know what if you see
the truth and you see the light and your
wife is not there
your actions will speak volumes yeah
yeah you know what i mean
for your husband yeah yeah
even even the same same team from the
other direction for sure yeah
you know this whole experience where you
had
anything you wanted
yeah
to just putting yourself completely in
god's hands
have you ever lacked anything
well
we lack
i don't mean like i mean like
necessities has god provided all of your
needs yes
and um i i don't want to get the wrong
impression to people here that god will
always come to in your own terms no
right he will come through in his own
time in his own term in his own way he
proved that through your marriage yeah
like okay doing the mission work is like
okay lord i need this now it doesn't
happen now let's say next month or next
year does it happen it happens
but not when it doesn't happen now you
think no god's not doing it for me you
know it's easily uh you can easily say
that a lot of people then god's not
answering your prayer
you mentioned something that i think
just kind of sparked my my memory of
something in matthew um when the rich
young ruler came to jesus and he is
sitting there you know asking jesus what
do i need to do to to have salvation
and you know jesus is very patient with
him you know he he he wants to lead him
to where the where the error is in his
life he doesn't just necessarily you
know give him a shopping list even
though he answers the question
saying you know hey
keep these commandments and he goes but
all these i have kept but he leaves out
a few of them he doesn't mention that
you know love god with all your heart
you know like
like have no other idols before you
and um so this comes from matthew 20 or
matthew 19 um
starting with uh
with about um verse 20 it says you know
he asks well what do i lack and jesus
said
if you will be perfect go and sell all
that you have and give to the poor and
you shall have treasure in heaven and
come and follow me
now i think a lot of people look at this
verse and they go oh well if you're rich
then all you need to do is just just you
know sell everything that's the point of
the story right that wasn't the point of
the story in fact god isn't against
wealth there are many people in the
bible i mean job there there's some very
wealthy people that god provided that
that wealth for but i think in this
particular case which is very similar to
what you guys had um it was really just
just realizing our hold on the things of
this world and saying that you need to
let those go and come and follow me i
mean that invitation right there that
jesus was giving to that young man was
to literally come and and be probably a
disciple
and here he's forsaking that over his
riches
i mean can you imagine in fact if you if
you read it closely
jesus never really extended that
invitation to judas
judas more or less just latched himself
on to that group
i think that guy would have been the one
holding all the money interesting yes
yes you know he was good with money yeah
i think he would have been the one to
hold the purse you know and distribute
to the pool
instead of judas
but obviously god lets people make their
own choices
and and i think when you read on to the
story a little bit further why we wanted
to do this story here is i love it that
his disciples are sitting there
listening to what's being said right
here and then they're just like you know
baffled with with when god says you know
it's hard for a rich man to enter into
the kingdom of heaven right when he says
that and and they're like well who
who can be saved right but then they
turn around and they say um
but lord and this is verse 27 matthew 19
peter said behold we have forsaken all
and followed you um what shall we have
therefore meaning like you know will we
be go into heaven we gave up everything
right listen to how jesus responds to
this he says verily i say to you that
you who which have followed me in the
regeneration when the son of the man
shall sit in the throne of his glory you
shall sit upon your twelve thrones
judging the twelve tribes of israel and
every one that forsake us is his house
his brothers his sisters his father his
mother or his wife or his children or
his lands for my name's sake shall
receive a hundred fold and inherit
everlasting life
you know it's it's it's just beautiful
that god is
he is not saying listen you need to
forsake all this stuff and and um you
know give it all up for me he's he's
literally promising look there's a
better way i'll show you a better way
and not only will i leave you there i
will give you a hundred times what you
thought would make you happy
amen so to me to hear your guys's
testimony of of really just you know how
god has worked in your lives and and you
guys are now actively involved in
ministry work and what about the peace
can you just talk a brief little moment
about that do you feel much more peace
absolutely absolutely awesome you know
something that i never experienced
before in my life people say dominican
by happiness and i was there i'm gonna
say no
not at all you know
now we're living we applicate the living
by faith you know because we want to
know that is it god is exist to you know
can provide for you
yes he is he even
sent people to pay for my
first son tuition can you imagine that i
was like wow this is mind-blowing
because god says when your heart has a
you know has a room for others
i'm gonna take care of you god says like
that and then
so that's why we just give everything to
the lord even yeah we thought we're
gonna live under the bridges and start
begging people no it's not like that
yeah we're not
i think there's a good point in matthew
13 44. heaven is like a onto a treasure
hidden in the field that's right that a
man goes in there to the field digs and
finds the treasure
hides it so nobody steals it
and then he goes home
with all the joy
he sells everything he has
to buy that field
a lot of people think i'm like okay oh
you're selling all these things you're
getting rid of your house's properties
to find joy no
if you
if you're selling without finding the
treasure you're selling for the wrong
reasons
a lot of people are actually doing this
quitting the career you know moving the
mountain serving people and everything
but without finding the joy it's a joy
first that you have to seek first
you know
and then automatically will you will
have the joy in doing that you know but
in doing so we find joy and this joy is
actually what's driving us okay
we don't probably don't need this thing
we can
live a simpler life and it's the happier
you become the longer you serve him the
sweeter he gets more money more problems
[Laughter]
well thank you guys so much for blessing
us with your testimony um if you guys
want to check out a little bit of their
ministry we'll put a link in the
description below they are actively
engaged and involved in ministry work um
you guys have a wide range of things
that you you guys are doing so um we'll
put a little link for you guys down
there but um you know i think the one
takeaway from this conversation today is
if you really truly honestly will give
god your heart and you will follow him
just like what jesus was suggesting he
will not only give you everlasting life
and a crown
when we when he comes back to take us
home but he will give us the peace here
and now and he will fulfill
all of those deep desires that we have
in our hearts and so we thank you guys
so much for checking us out and uh we'll
see you guys next friday
[Music]
you